This video is sponsored by Archero!
Welcome everybody, it's me!
You know me...
It's all about me!
Felix: Hey guys, it's me. Marzia: Bye! (silently walks away)
Felix: Come back. I'm kidding I brought Marzia back. <3
Marzia: Mmhmm (why am I here)
Felix: Because I need to do a sponsorship...
First of all, do you want to try some G-Fuel? Marzia: Ooh
Glug Glug Glug (Use the Code: Pewds to get 10% off in this delicious drink!)
Let's get into the game (Let's just jump into it!)
Archero (Greatest Game ever made)
Felix: Have you played this game before? Marzia: No. Oh, It looks cute!
It looks cute! - Marzia 2019
*skratta*
Felix: So the gist of this game is that you have all these skills Marzia: Mmm (Yup I'm listening!)
F: You can start playing and I'll talk M: Oh! Okay x2
And you can combine them for billions of different skills (BILLIONS!)
I don't know if it's billions
But basically, you start up simple level one, as an archer.  (like a noob)
M: Yeah? F: You should go upwards
So intuitive! You don't even have to... *skratta* (*Random Marzia Voice*)
Okay, so you shoot while standing still
So you want to be able to walk (like a normal person does)
Okay, so dodge the arrows and then when you want to shoot stand still for a second (less than a second standing *SHOOTS*)
F: There you go niice (10/10 Very Nice!) M: Ohhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
Oh my god! He has angel so beautiful
*So Sexy*
WOW! It's another Warrior!
(Great Acting Felix!) (10/10 Very Nice) (CANWEBRINGBACKVERYNICEBYFELIX)
Check Out Archero guys! (Yea like that will make me play it)
I like It!
F: Hey, watch out, watch out M: What what what what what? F: Damn
No, I didn't
No, I didn't (yes you did)
Yeah, I like how they uhhh... set it up, yeah.
I haven't actually played that much, I kinda wanna...
*Missle Enters* (Great Editing Sive 1/2)
WOOAH! You've got a Critical! (*Anime WoW Sound Effect*)
You're dead. You beat EIGHT percent of players.
That's a gamer moment *Brofist*
Alright, here we go, it's PewDiePie's turn
Alright, here we go, it's Poppy Gloria's turn
F: I'll be trying not to block the entire-- M: Well, its not really fair cause you knew what to do and I didn't know
F: I did not know! I'm a gamer I just know what to do automatically M: Mhmm
*Felix and Marzia focused gaming*
F: So Marzia M: Mhm?
How's life for people that don't know what you're doing? *skratta*
M: It's good
M: Why do you always ask me these things!
M: Everything is great F: Yeah M: Ummm *Lip Smack*
The weather is nice... (Real gamers don't go outside)
Real gamers don't go outside (or lonely people like me)
F: Okay, so do we want the HP boost, fire circle
F: Or side arrows? M: Fire Circle
F: Fire Circle. Oh, dope! M: Oooooh F: Okay
(Oh damn look at the fire circles doing work)
F: Oh damn, look at the fire circles doing work!
F: Now we can stand tactical advantage
behind the wall and still do damage
Aren't you impressed?
*Gasp* What is this?? nande kore?
(なんで これ for all you weebs)
*Amazing Acting 10/10*
*Smiles like the Devil*
Are you laughing at me or for me? (M: Neither, Cause I'm taking your SOUL)
F: You found an angel M: I liked the pause there
*Both Cute Skratta*
F: Okay M: See the fire thing was a good choice
F: The fire choice was a good choice
This is how you know you're a gamer, 'cause you have gamer intuition
F: Just don't die. That's all you gotta do Marzia. Just DON't DIE. (Nope she will)
Oh
*Bangs his head*
F: I bring you on to the most esteemed gaming channel of all time and this is how you perform? (Yup because wamen aren't games)
F: Why do I keep dissing you? (because she suuuuucks) I'm Sorry, Thank You, Marzia.
M: Yeah, you're welcome
You were supposed to do my hair, look how I look like (Hitler is that you?) (Sorry Pewds JK)
I told you do you want me to do your hair and you say
F: *Mumbling Talk* M: "Does this hair look like it needs help?"
Again, you get another chance
M: Wait, you see?
F: Yeah, but you have the ability
*Marzia's suspicious look*
M: Mmm F: Yeah, I think so -- No wait! No you don't! *gasps* No, it restarts (like every mobile games)
F: Aww... M: It's okay, it's okay. Now we're going to do it so well.
*Footage of doing terribly at the game*
Walks into wall, okay *laughs*
It is slightly different though isn't it
Fun Trivia Time! M: I'm so into the game
M: I'm so into the game
ARCHERO, where do you think that comes from?
What do you mean? The word?
ARCHER + HERO
(Top 10 anime crossovers)
Archero
You can fly beau-- Our postman is coming
Alright, you keep playing
The company HABBY
Is Happy + Hobby
F: Here we go with some more fun trivia, Marzia
M:Sure
*Fails*
M: Oh. What?
F: Did you die?
Okay so we were -- I was correct
It is a rogue-lite which means it's procedurally generated the way you play it.
M: I got all of that.
F: I know these are big words for you, Marzia
*Laughs*
So, the fights are unique, basically
Lots of content for
With more than 50 species of bosses and over
200 horrible-- This is how good I am a games. I do promos and I play at the same time
200 horrible monsters you can play for a long time without even getting bored. Well, I'm not bored yet
F: I don't know about you, Marzia
M: No, I like it
F: What should I get?
M: Bolt
Dude, I was gonna pick Bolt
Don't walk into them!
M: Don't worry, I got the bolt
F: Whoa, you got the bolt!
F: Use the bolt!
M: Oh :(
F: Ok, pay
M:Pay, pay, pay
F:Ok,  yeah
M: Hehehe (like all girlfriends do)
Yeah
You might want to try and finish one up there you go you got it
F: This is my girl, this is my gamer girl right here
M: *Walks into rocks*
Both: *Kek*
F: Everyone a round of applause M: Thank you
F: You beat 16% of players! M: 16!! Ayyyy
Hey, 16% of gamers you can
F: Alright. What do we got here? M: Too strong
F: You can upgrade M: Did they say how far the number one rank has gone?
whoa
John Wick
How far has he gone?
I'm about to show just how far the number one gamers-
WOAH
See this, Marzia, this is where we add really epic music to the edit even though the gameplay-
Doesn't match it
M: Poison Touch F: Poison Touch
Oh okay so I hit them once and they take damage, look
So now I can just sit here and chill while he dies
F: That's called gamer strategy. M: Mmmm very brave of you
"That's very brave of you"? Was that sarcasm?
*Marry me, Marzia*
Keeping a distance... and I still got hit
Jesus Christ
I actually wanna perform, I just can't
"Oh, I know all about that," Marzia says
M: I'm playing now.
F: No please please
M: Why? F: Okay okay okay you go
Are you saying that I'm not good enough to play?
I actually want to see how far I can go
So what?
Are you saying that I can't?
F: That's not what I said
M: That's what happened
Holy crap, you leave me with this hell
We do one, that's fair
Alright, we're gonna-- *gasps* boss!
What does he do? He shoots fireballs. You shoot fireballs like Angel
M: He's kinda cute! F: He's kinda cute though
Hit or miss? I shoot the dragon bish, huh?
I'm disgusting
Ah!
Come on come on, come on
Pulse
PULSE
Yeah!
Lucky Wheel!
Holy Goly Moley what did we get?
Great great great, aw damn it
I will actually play this game unironically,
I like it
F: What about you, Marzia?
M: I think it's pretty good.
Look at the poison doing that work. We we made the right choice with the poison, Marzia, I must say.
Yess
Nice. Good job.
F: No damage
M: We're going far!
F: Yeah!
and beyond
*gasps* No, I messed up
New best at least.
We beat... how many percent?
100% of gamers
We beat a hundred percent of gamers.
Alright guys download Archero today
There's a link for iOS in the description or click here to download for Android
Big thanks to Archero for sponsoring this video but the biggest thanks to Marzia.
See you next sponsorship, Marzia
Bye!